[музыка]
Ребята у нас в Японии у нас в Японии
Судя по узким глазам Я уже близок А
здесь вообще страшно не любят и
раздражается водители визы все с кем мы
работаем японцы они прям очень нервно
воспринимают Поэтому у них это не
принято ждать у них вот во время вышли
всё поехали а тот кто остался должны
догонять на такси там это их проблемы
поэтому из уважения друг другу Из
уважения к нации лучше не опаздывать
Меня зовут Владимир Я эксперт центра
Кайзер поездке я буду переводить солнце
раз пройду инструкции в любой поездке
Ребята в любой поездке самое главное это
управлять двумя вещами Первое это
управление своими ожиданиями потому что
любая поездка это перемещение с точки А
в точку б и как бы организаторы все Не
продумали все продумать невозможно
соответствует ожиданиям одного человека
это одно соответствие между ожиданием
целой группы это сложно один негативный
человек в компании в коллективе
деморализует 9 эффективных людей вы сами
знаете да один критикан всегда может и
прах разбивать любые инициативы и так
далее поэтому
обращайте внимание на позитивные
отношения и свои кислые рожи не портит
нам наш праздник Всем привет Меня зовут
Денис я
сам из Молдовы но последние 12 лет живу
в Дубае и последние 10 лет занимаюсь там
недвижимостью из Казани это республика
Татарстан входит в Российскую Федерацию
Я работаю в транспортной компании Всем
здравствуйте
Я из Андижан
Я занимаюсь
экомец маркетплейсом питания в общем у
меня свой образовательный онлайн клуб
финансы инвестиции личностный рост
менять дидак зовут город Талдыкорган Это
возле Алматы
занимаюсь
общепитан это ресторанным бизнес фастфуд
мы занимаемся логистикой А в основном
специализируемся на максимальных
перевозках центрального азизе
Вот это футболка
на Первом свете в Анталии Японию недавно
было интересно ждал этого тура тема
кайдзен мне очень близка она манит
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
иду не попробовали Но как это
подогревается потрясающе
крутой
самое главное
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
по-японской традиции Начинать надо со
сладкого с точки зрения питания вообще
правильно начинается с фруктов фрукты
сладкое потом слева направо очень нежный
еще полностью не разобрался во вкусе но
это очень
вкусная свежая рыба Ну я в восторге мы
сейчас пока вы будете ходить с твоей
тарелочки уже начали есть
соседская тарелке
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
Когда вы находитесь в этом мире вы
оказываете на это мир воздействие
давите на стул сейчас сидите А вы дышите
воздухом Там и так далее вы окажете на
этот мир воздействие Когда вы на этот
мир оказывается Вот здесь вы порождаете
три силы Первое противодействие это
второй закон Ньютона соответственно
противодействие даже ты сейчас говоришь
я пойду в ресторан
мы будем против
администрация ресторан закрыт но
обязательно будет еще силы содействия
кто-то скажет Я тоже еще не против
перекусить
есть взаимодействие
Итак нейтральный но это тоже сила и твоя
задача
уменьшить противодействие увеличить
содействие и привлечь на свою сторону
взаимодействия мы все считаем что самый
ценный ресурс это время
а почему мы так считаем потому что время
не возобновляемое оно уходит в одну
сторону так соответственно думаю во
время
на самом деле самый дорогой ресурс это
энергия
энергия Потому что у Вас могут быть цели
у вас может быть время но у вас нету сил
это делать соответственно броситься на
вашем теле если у вас нет энергии
энергии есть жизнь то есть если есть
жизнь только тогда время имеет ценность
если жизнь у вас нет Время не имеет
никакой ценности А теперь что дает
энергию энергию дают три физические
составляющие воздух вода еда
так вот заметьте все что действительно
нам важно воздухом бесплатно
вот то что нам действительно
а то что нам вообще нахрен не нужно
так вот ценить вы
мудрость заключается в том что вы Цените
не то что люди ценят а то что
по-настоящему не сможете обойтись
без воздуха вы не обойдетесь без воды не
обойдетесь без пищи не обойдете Вот
именно это надо ценить понимаете и таким
образом то же самое и с людьми Ты должен
Ценить тех людей которые без которых ты
обойти не сможешь
[музыка]
Сегодня у нас в первой половине дня
будет теория дальше будет практика все
эти четыре дня с Вами будут работать
Самые выдающиеся преподаватели сенсея
которые есть в Тойоте и самый лучший для
нас награды будет если вы эти знания
которые получите сможете использовать на
практике своей деятельности
[музыка]
я председатель акционерного общества
мифуна Меня зовут унемура я также
являюсь основателем данной компании
основал я её 43 года тому назад Наша
компания производит детали для
поставщиков Тойоты занимаемся мы
производством металлических изделий
кайденом является Процесс поиска потери
их устранения и
получение с этого прибыли
ребята вот смотрите то что я на улице
вам были мои догадки Они все
подтвердились видели да смотрите 31
миллион долларов 3 процента годовых
строительство
50 процентов отдачи на капитал Кто
говорил что 3 процента это мало это
суперские деньги конечно
[музыка]
сейчас перед нами выступит
вице-президент Toyota
расскажет про алгоритм решение проблем и
всем инструментов
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
а в реальных проектах когда вот даю
теорию объясняя общую концепцию я потом
всегда даю какие-то конкретные примеры
Либо мы решаем практические задачи чтобы
отработать методику прежде чем мы начнем
Давайте немножко с организуемся нам
нужно с вами поделиться на две команды я
писал здесь без операторов 18 человек
поэтому по 9 человек в команду
соответственно вам нужно столы сейчас
будут выстроить просто в линию в ряд
рабочих мест
[музыка]
самое главное
вот так вот понимаете да на карповал
Дайте мне мне дать
[музыка]
всё правильно правильно
на самом деле
это очень круто и команда
надо Обмениваться
[музыка]
мы подошли к третьему Дню обучения
Давайте сегодня тоже узнаем что-нибудь
новое Сегодня у нас новый Сэнсэй его
зовут на кодзима и он нам скоро себе
расскажет Сегодня мы в основном
сосредоточимся на времени
производственного цикла То есть это
время которое проходит с момента когда
детали и Материалы поступили на завод до
выпуска конечного готового продукта И
сейчас я вместо того чтобы это объяснять
хотел бы чтобы вы сами это ощутили на
себе
[музыка]
производственный процесс
реальный производственный процесс у себя
на производстве
[аплодисменты]
и сегодня мы
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
мы находимся в технологическом музее
Toyota очень классно в конце компании
Toyota я вот не знал то что изначально
они занимались текстилем а потом стали
такой громадной компании
автопроизводителем просто потрясающий
тут гуляешь смотришь как тут двигается
какие они решения там находили какие-то
определенные периоды времени Просто
подрешающие потом Даже эти оборудования
переоборудование делали из них подушки
безопасности и так далее У меня здесь
очень много инсайтов в том плане как
компания постоянно
здесь очень много примеров тех же самых
двигателей например и так далее
[музыка]
просто шикарно Это история которую ты
можешь прикоснуться прямо здесь сейчас
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
своими 30 лет как раньше
холодильник
[музыка]
очень важные части нашей программы
[аплодисменты]
а рассказываю наш план на сегодня мы
находимся в городе Киото Это старая
столица Японии Она вторая по счету
официальная столица
[музыка]
по телевизору это все видел но намного
ощущение другие
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
это прекрасно конечно
и погода Сегодня отличная наконец-то Мы
доехали до обеда интересно место
посетили это
выше дворец императора
уникальные места как я понял это место
для медитации
как они лежат
[музыка]
впечатление
прекрасное А самое главное у нас еще
впереди их масса этих прекрасных
впечатлений
природа как они
бережно упоминает отношение как
скандинавских странах Финляндии
удовлетворение какое-то чувствуется даже
При таком количестве людей
[музыка]
там было комфортно
Вот именно в Киото на самом последнем
когда мы ходили храм Чистой воды
называется там очень много сакур и они
такие именно как вот ухоженные
Вот именно в Японском вот или и все это
цветет благоухает я именно сегодня
как-то вот когда ветерок дул или видел
две серии такие эти
лепестки я задумался мимолетности жизни
о том что она яркая красивая но она
быстро проходит Вот смотри
это сад камней
вот здесь 15 камней Вот но один Всегда
не видно С какой позиции не смотрел
всегда один будет перекрываться
с любой точки такого университет
Я когда надо посмотрел я подумал
вспомнил
что мы всегда ориентируемся на то что мы
знаем но очень важно то пусть даже
небольшой чего мы не знаем оно может
сильнее повлечь все что мы знаем
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
Япония
от остальных
очень прикольно
[музыка]
обнимаю
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]